dan or had a gas I guess we better start
scavenging
more fuel won't help us now
the way that blood plague is progressing
your friend won't last long without a
place to rest hey everyone its Peter
Brown standing in for Alessandra Barbosa
for his review of state of decay - state
of decay - sometimes feels like a far
too real representation of the mundane
reality that comes with surviving a
zombie apocalypse with its myriad
systems and emphasis on survival and
humanity it attempts to tie together its
incessant prodding for risky supply runs
and the needs to care for other hopeless
survivors but it fails to generate any
interesting or various scenarios and
doing so consistently being on the hunt
for food resources to craft ammunition
and survivors to bolster your ranks
doesn't always translate into
captivating gameplay like the first game
from undead labs state of decay too
infrequently checks in with an
overarching narrative you're given the
choice of three pairs of survivors to
start off with each with their own bare
bones background stories these stories
don't really matter but your decision
does define your starting area and the
preliminary survivors you'll team up
with to combat a growing sickness called
the blood plague that boils down to a
static number of zombie infested
settlements that you'll need to first
scout out and ultimately destroy with
grotesque beating plague hearts at the
center
these fights are the only real way to
measure progression through state of
decay to s otherwise open-ended mission
each one you take down strengthens the
rest forcing you to step back and
regroup before attempting to blow up
another one unfortunately their basic
action set-pieces at their core that
much variety to help shake up the
otherwise monotonous scavenging state of
decay - is primarily about survival and
with that it brings the same baggage
that the genre is known for although
you're spared the stress of dealing with
individual metres for hunger and thirst
will instead be engaging with ones that
affect your community food medical
supplies and crafting materials all
factored in to the stability of your
community and the overall mood of your
survivors governing how well you're
doing although your settlement initially
requires some quick work to get on its
feet state of decay - hardly feels like
it will fail you for slacking on your
daily duties resources only become
troublesome when you need them to craft
something specific such as ammo or
plague cures they're short-lived
problems though which hardly force you
to pause and think about how you're
setting up your settlement it's rare for
state of decay - to make you feel
pressure over the choices you make which
just makes its subsystems feel shallow
there is potential for strategic play
that feels left by the wayside as an
example your base features a threat
level which governs how likely you are
to attract a zombie attack creating new
structures or powering them with
generators creates noise and in turn
increases the likelihood of an attack
for a certain period of time but even at
the highest level a community of just
six members is often enough to fend off
these attacks without needing specific
intervention from you of the handful of
moments that my character was Radia to
return the fight was over by the time I
arrived all structures intact all
settlers unharmed
state of decay to squander systems like
this by not giving you a reason to
engage with them seriously it strips out
the decision-making you might expect if
your aim is to continually bring new
survivors to a settlement but also worry
about their well-being your encounters
with each new face should feature some
scrutiny as to what they bring to the
table their distinct ability to set them
apart from each other but not in a way
that forces you to make tough decisions
about who to invite into your settlement
the sheer breadth of options on offer
might trick you into thinking that
scrutinizing each potential addition is
key but that's not the case
frequently state of decay too reminds
you that clashing personalities are
leading to fights at home base but these
never escalated to a point we are
required to take action you never feel
the need to exile an existing character
or deny entry to one based on their lack
of a specific skill there's definitely a
lack of strategy missing from this
component entirely which strips out the
potential for exciting I'll be a
difficult decision making and combat
isn't as dynamic as some character
specific abilities might suggest but it
is satisfying them unless a single
button is used for attacks which
depending on your weapon of choice could
inflict blunt knock-down damage or
whittle an enemy down limb by limb the
gory finishers and gruesome sound
effects really bring a weight to the
melee action even if you're just
mindlessly mashing the same button until
your stamina expires firearms feature -
and ammunition for them is actually far
more abundant than you might expect
guns attract more zombies even with
silencers but it's the sluggish aiming
that's more frustrating in practice
[Applause]
state of decay - does a fair job of
mixing things up with the introduction
of some new enemy types while some less
interesting additions such as exploding
bloaters feature may be more than they
should - others shake up combat in
delightful ways
Farrell's will jolt around at high
speeds avoiding your melee swings and
making firearms a nightmare to connect
with similarly juggernauts make up the
largest foes you'll face on the frontier
they'll soak up hits from vehicles and
rounds of ammunition before giving you a
chance to take them down with a
satisfying execution combined with
regular limbering enemies that will
quickly surround you juggernauts make
fights more about clever crowd control
but big crowds can be stressful for
other reasons state of decay - runs
poorly even on Xbox one x despite not
standing out graphically in any regard
the framerate will frequently dip well
below 30 frames per second sometimes
even locking up momentarily as a result
inputs often feel unresponsive which
becomes annoying when you're trying to
swing your way out of a supply run gone
wrong this is all stacked on top of a
motion blur problem that is so
aggressive that even the slightest
movement turns your surroundings into an
unattractive smudge and bugs are
prominent - and can range from slightly
annoying to near game breaking graphical
hitches are frequent including enemies
clipping through the environment and
sometimes having whole hordes stuck on
single sections of the map physics will
miscalculate launching your vehicle in
the air from a slight touch at low
speeds companions are also particularly
prickly with some disappearing from
missions for no reason
state of decay - is in rough shape as it
stands these technical faults might have
been easier to overlook if state of
decay - had enough depth to keep you
interested in the long run in its
current form it settles into a rhythm
that might be enjoyable for a few hours
but it never offers much in the way of
surprises excitement or motivation state
of decay - feels like the limbering
enemies that populate its country
mountains aimless wandering and just out
of place
we love some